the fourth generation mazda2 has been in
German car showroom since February the
supermini which is also badged as the
mazda demio has shed its conservative
image its new look is sleeker and
sporty-er
long long
mazda is targeting its m2 at younger
image conscious buyers looking to make a
self confident appearance and here the
Japanese model definitely delivers its
striking radiator grille and sharp
headlights are similar to those used in
the mazda 3 and mazda 6 and have already
received a warm reception what to
exclude our likes the crisp five-speed
transmission and good steering he says
the suspension is a little stiff but
makes the mazda feel safe he stresses
that they 4-cylinder engine runs
smoothly petzl it does our test model
has a 66 kilowatt gasoline engine with
1.5 liters of cubic capacity and 148
newton meters of torque at a time when
rough-and-ready 3-cylinder engines are
all the rage the mazdas quiet 4-cylinder
power plant makes for a pleasant change
things get a bit noisier at this test
site though here the mazda reveal some
weaknesses on the obstacle course it
understeers at times and over stares at
others though the ESP kicks in and
stabilizes things and a braking distance
of almost 39 meters for a car going 100
kilometers an hour just isn't acceptable
these days unlike the car makers larger
models the mazda 2 has an analog
speedometer still the instruments have a
modern look the interior design boasts
unusual elements like these different
air vents the japanese model has a style
all its own with its USB ports and
bluetooth the multimedia system should
satisfy the demands of young buyers it
can be controlled centrally using a dial
or through the touchscreen
the trunk is a maximum cargo capacity of
500 90 liters so there's plenty of room
for luggage unfortunately the high trunk
sill makes it hard to load and unload
when a DAC put the supermini to the test
it consumed 4.9 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers that's fairly thrifty though
not quite as good as the manufacturer's
claimed average fuel consumption figures
of 4.5 liters
then what's that's demand from a DAC
says the new Mazda tues fresh design
will certainly attract many potential
buyers who will then be won over by its
inner fruit juice white Sun belden our
test car sells for just over 16,000
euros in Germany pretty pricey for a
supermini but take the smaller gasoline
engine and forego the trimmings and you
can pick up a Monsta to for less than
13,000